the inquiry into the capital riots may
be exposing donald trump as corrupt and
i said you're asking me
to do something that's never been done
in history
the history of the united states
as complicit president trump summoned
the mob assembled the mob and lit the
flame of this attack
but in the places where it matters has
its swung opinion
not a bit
i truly believe that he won the election
in all my heart and soul
do you think trump will run again i hope
he runs again he's got your vote
and everybody else i know
this is rural pennsylvania spend time
here and it's clear trump's spell runs
deep they believe in him still they
believe his presidency was stolen and
they believe he will come again
never mind that it's president trump's
allies republicans who are now revealing
his attempts to hold on to power just
listen to farmers mark and harry i think
it was all orchestrated a hollywood
presentation of
something that's not real
i think that whole thing's a witch hunt
when you have a trial and there's only
one
one side heard
even though they were the
they were the those close to donald
trump who are now saying that they told
him that he lost they told him to to
stand down donald trump has had
people that call himself his friends
stab him in the back over and over again
this is a society too divided to be
swung by an inquiry in washington even
one warning of a grave threat to the
nation's democratic stability no here
all you feel is the enduring power of
trumpism and would you vote for donald
trump if he if he stands again in 2024 i
probably would still
i liked his policies more than anything
look i wasn't crazy about the tweeting
sometimes i didn't agree with everything
but it was a positive nature he brought
to the public
he was uh
he split the nation
he it's not positive is it well positive
to me is if you can motivate someone to
progress and he was breaking that
barrier down to give the power back to
the people
consistent polling suggests that 70
percent of republicans continue to
believe trump's baseless stolen election
claims among them the judge of the
kempton fair a moment with kelly cuts to
the heart of this nation's problems i
find out the truth because i do a lot of
digging myself i am on different
applications with social media
but that might not be the truth i mean
like the broader question how do
americans if they can't trust the media
they can't trust the politicians how do
they find out the truth about anything
well
i think they need to have conversations
with friends i try to talk to my friends
about what i feel is going on versus
what we're being told by mainstream
media
kelly is among millions in an echo
chamber a place where donald trump
continues to convince them that they've
been robbed that they can't trust their
own elections
that puts this country in a dangerous
place mark stone sky news in
pennsylvania